here's 2045 people and the real world is
a terrible place to live in so people
would rather live in technology much
like 2018 except nowhere near as cool
let's talk about ready player one reason
to see ready player number one directing
and visual effects alright so there's
been a lot of hype around this movie a
lot of hype and a lot of anticipation
which you gotta give this film credit
for no matter what is its spill burg
definitely returning to some awesome ass
spectacle and the visual effects in this
movie are dynamite early on in the film
there's an opening action sequence that
is teased all over the trailers and I
just remember being that theater going
oh wow it's impressive in the way that
he's able to point and capture and you
know really make the action scenes
cacophonous but also dynamic yeah
nothing this movie is only about the 80s
a nostalgia factor but given that there
is a heavy 80s element it is kind of
cool to see Spielberg come full circle
because he's definitely one of the
voices that had a hand in crafting yeah
and what Pete's so many people are
nostalgic for about the 80s what this
movie is an odd way a love letter to in
a strange way is very medically if
Spielberg coming full circle we're gonna
paint a mosh to himself at times in
terms of films that he's done in like
the past 10 years or so that just aimed
to be entertainment
I'm usually have a hard time getting on
board which is finding the CBO
thoroughly throughout a really
entertaining time I think he really
succeeds here I was really entertained
pretty much for the entire film that's
not like the best script in movie in the
world but in terms of a visual feast a
lot of futuristic sci-fi excitement he
totally delivers on it and I
I'm really I walked away pretty happy
with the film yeah yeah and even if
you're not a hundred percent planned I
can't imagine you won't find some of
these places and locations and and
moments dazzling well there is
definitely something in there that
you're gonna be awestruck by because
there's also a wide variety of locations
into a Oasis it's like a much bigger
world than the real world but there's
one scene I'm not gonna spoil it but
they jump into a specific movie and that
sequence alone is pretty pretty
impressive I also want to say that
especially for someone like me who has
been actually catching up more on 80s
movies lately I've been getting back
into gaming recently I'm not like heavy
into it but just with in 2018 alone the
past four months I beat the last of us
have you Uncharted I'm only like two
chapters away for finishing uncharted 2
and I've been playing some Resident Evil
6 and my girlfriend the least like
Resident Evil but just getting back my
mind in touch with that felt especially
awesome to me to be awesome yeah and I
mean if you look at just the concept
you're like yeah I guess in the future I
can see how this would happen Oh totally
totally especially with VR advancing now
ready play a reason to see number 2
mm-hmm
nostalgia and pop-culture references
okay I'll be the first to admit there's
plenty of times where we'll throw in
footage I'm like I remember when I was
doing my reaction I said this about the
movie and it ended up being right
there's things about it where I was
pretty wrong about I'm not familiar with
the book when I saw the trailers for
this I kept teasing a lot of the same
nostalgia references they would be doing
in this movie so I was really under the
impression that we're gonna get like a
few things that show up for a second
this movie is loaded this is the
ultimate crossover movie yeah oh the
main thing at homes in Oz 80s nostalgia
there's pop-culture references to
modern-day things there's pop-culture
references to stuff from the 90s there's
a whole wide variety of references in
this film and it's such a big part of
the movie and I think what really
impressed me with it was how well
justified the movie is because in the
first 10 of 20 minutes of this movie
they're setting up the world of what the
Oasis is they're setting up at the world
also really loves the Cree
of the Oasis character played by Mark
Rylance who won ver bridge of spies you
see that this guy built the Oasis and a
lot of his love comes from all these
things that are being referenced within
the movie itself and because the world
loves the Creator it makes sense why
they all become obsessed with the same
things the Creator loves hence you get a
bunch of nostalgia and a bunch of
references that are so well justified so
when they start showing up on screen
there's a plenty of stuff that just
shows up for like a second and it's like
whatever but there's a lot of things
they really utilize things I don't want
to give away I was really amazed by how
there was some badass [ __ ] of this movie
yeah do you hear that Greg what that's
the sound of millions of blu-ray players
in the future pausing to pick out all
the sequences like there's no way I
caught every reference yeah and I mean
if you're a gamer too you're definitely
gonna catch some stuff in there like
there's a little something for I can't
imagine that they missed anybody now
entirely this movie definitely does lean
towards the eighties and eighties
sensibilities but but there's something
in here from everywhere reason to see
number three the cast where there's a
little discussion we have before putting
this on the list there's a difference
between cast and characters there's no
other there's some good characters in
here you know they're dual reasons not
to see section of this video the cast
though regardless is really good there's
a whole bunch of actors in here the lead
I shared and he does a really good job
of what he's given to no one really
talks about the characters when it comes
to this movie but when you think about
the performances especially looking back
I'm like well that's a big part of what
helped me be invested in this like you
said it's definitely more of a plot
movie not a character parent being a
character piece but the character
motives who the characters are are very
important is servicing the story the
actors do put in their best and there's
some characters in here that are more
fun than others Mark Rylance who clearly
was having a lot of fun with his role ty
Sheridan is more interesting than a lot
of the other ones because he's the lead
so he gets more screen time than
everyone else yeah everybody shows up
and brings their personality and I guess
I can't entirely I mean I would love
well-written character as always but
this is a movie that also borrows from
types like these characters
our types and it's supposed to hearken
back to I felt like I was watching one
of those 80s movies but updated to now
in a sort of meta way so yeah you do get
a lot of cool character actors who all
bring a charm and those are your
character reason not to see number one
some lackluster elements yeah there's
there's about three things that John and
I were able to think of a forehand kind
of lacked a little bit like how I was
talking about in the car was there's not
anything in this movie I actually don't
like there's just some things I felt
could have been enhanced or better
handled or Richard exactly yeah that's
probably the best word for it it kind of
goes that way for all the characters
there's a couple of characters that
especially towards the end of the movie
Spielberg starts capturing it in a way
where each treats it like these
characters have some bigger backstory
and I couldn't help but think these guys
definitely had a couple of deleted
scenes in a day that kind of gave some
exposition as to who the hell these two
are Ben Mendelsohn's character
especially was one where I was
incredibly conflicted in certain areas
because Ben Mendelsohn is an amazing
actor to me he actually gets a lot to do
in this movie if you really think about
it involved in this he's very involved
it's just the way his character was
written he's kind of portrayed as a joke
of a villain he is the villain of the
movie but he's portrayed in a way where
you never think you'll have a chance and
the movie makes it clear this guy
doesn't get it yeah they make him out to
be kind of a joke and I thought the
movie could have benefited for some
actual intensity but if you had been
Mendelsohn feel like an actual threat
and not just some dude who randomly got
to this position you know yeah it does
hamper for me some of the tension
because I never doubted where anything
was gonna end up I never thought that
anything was truly threatening I was
mostly like okay how are we gonna figure
these obstacles out yeah in this movie
around the time they almost make an
interesting choice with Ben Mendelsohn's
character you know it gets dismantled
right away and you're like oh yeah
you're just a sniffler that's it yeah
you know just cuz he has so many lines
that he gets a lot to do like it brings
things those scenes but yeah it's is not
an overly threat
I personally don't really have pacing
issues with this movie but I know other
people have had pacing issues with this
movie and I know you have some pacing
issues yeah I mean I partly to is I
think you were more pulled in the mean
if you're really pulled in I don't think
you'll notice it so much and I don't
think it was poorly paced I just thought
it was kind of blocky
I guess is the way I would describe it
it kind of I can see why one would like
a brick yeah and I think the big
complaint that I'm hearing a lot of
people say how they felt the real world
outside of the Oasis was just really
dull and not that interesting I'm like
well yeah that's kind of my response to
that is yeah this isn't supposed to be
it's like how they set up the movie then
no one wants to live in the real world
I'm sure he could have done some things
to make the real world more interesting
but like when we watch The Matrix takes
in the real world beyond a couple things
like make the real world a place that's
also important yeah because they were
saying like the real world is just this
terrible place to live in now let's get
a better sense of what they mean by that
you know that's probably what the
element is that people wanted to feel
more of however I'll say that there's
scenes in the real world that are just
fine to me the most interesting thing to
me about the real world scenes was the
fact that it looked like they shot those
on actual films Oasis is almost all
effects so that looked very digital in
the real world looked very film and that
was about the one thing I was like oh
cool but the rest of it it doesn't seem
like much of this matters to the real
world even though it kind of does but
you know that once this all resolves
everyone's just gonna go keep escaping
the real world
yes the real world is kind of a ringer
to me in this movie I will say there's
elements of the production aside of the
real world that I appreciate it because
while the Oasis pays a lot of tribute to
80s nostalgia I kind of felt like the
real world felt in a way how 80s movies
portrayed the future yeah it's very
slummy it's not like a neill blomkamp
like realistic kind of way I don't know
if this is an issue or not but but the
real world feels designed but not lived
in to me oh it's a cool eye it's a good
way to put it yeah it's good but we're
never gonna spend that much time here
and and some of the stuff they seem like
they cut out of the movie like I said is
in the real world which makes me go how
did you get from here to here though if
they're real people around trying
to you know do certain this so yeah like
it's just kind of a ringer to me in this
movie a bit reason not to see number two
he just might not be a part of the
specific audience or this kind of movie
it's kind of thick and there's a lot
going on it's very fast-paced in a lot
of areas and there's a when they're in
the Oasis there's a lotta [ __ ] the water
I don't at you and a lot of it is
references and nostalgia and the movie
is about that it's not just some tactic
or manipulative thing it's a part of the
world you just might not be a part of
the obvious that gives a [ __ ] about that
kind of thing you're in a gaming but
you're not into the 80s you can still
like it cuz of the gaming but if you're
into like the eighties all I missed
all's you might be in sit because of
that it's a giant blockbuster that's
more for a specific kind of audience
honestly that is very prevalent at the
moment and fandom and nostalgia are both
very big things right now but if you're
like the Spielberg person who loves like
bridge of spies it's time to post this
might not be your film this is like when
I watch stranger things it's like
they're elements of this that are for me
and for some reason the only response I
had to it was oh cool
it never swept me personally up and I'm
not a hundred percent sure why that is I
felt like for most of it I was pretty
swept up before watching this movie I
saw the early Twitter reactions to it
I'm like yeah that's about 5050 with
everyone on this movie you're looking
for something really to connect to I
feel like it's missing that if if all
this stuff that everyone loves is your
connection point you're gonna love this
yeah that's my mean it's a specific
group yeah so in the end I for me
personally I would I would say that a
lot of what I was worried about and that
I was thinking that movie might do I
will admit that I was wrong I enjoyed
the hell out of it I think there are so
many more reasons to see this movie than
there are not to see the movie this is a
movie you have to check out for yourself
and for me I think there's a lot of cool
stuff in it I appreciate a lot of it I
think it's cool I had a good time you
know I I didn't love this this is a
movie that objectively I look at it and
I go yeah this is really cool there's a
lot of stuff to enjoy here there's a lot
of filmmaking to be appreciated it's not
necessarily it didn't sweep me up it's
not necessarily my cup of tea all the
way but uh you know definitely see it
for yourself and check it out it's
pretty cool alright guys well ready
player one it came out on Wednesday so
what did you think of ready player one
to live up to the hype for you are you
one of the people who is really
anticipating it and to live up to the
hype or not leave your comments down
below you guys can subscribe to the real
rejects please click that notification
bell so you can get notified when a
video is actually out and check us out
on patreon full-length TV show reactions
over there weekly Q&A thank you to
everyone who's been joining us over
there so far would love to have you
there